on this 316th day of 15 days to slow the
spread
president joe biden has a message for
all of us and it's a pretty simple one
it's common sense if you ask me
this pandemic is going to take a whole
lot longer
before we can return to normal i'm going
to shut down the virus but not i never
said i'd do it in two months i said it
took a long time to get here
it's going to take a long time to beat
it and so we have millions of people out
there who are
who have the virus we're just for the
first day i think correct me if i'm
wrong i've been doing other things
this morning speaking with foreign
leaders but one of the things i think
this is one of the first days that the
numbers actually come down the number of
deaths
and the number on a daily basis and the
number of hospitalizations etc
it's going to take time it's going to
take a heck of a lot of time
and we still have as dr fauci constantly
points out
it's one thing when we have mass
how can i say it politely mass disregard
of the warnings about
not wearing masks and wearing masks and
and social distancing and failure to
social distance and
people getting together on holidays in
ways that weren't recommended etc
we see first thing that happens is we
see
the uh the number of infections go up
then you see the hospitalizations go up
then you see the deaths go up
poor joe biden he's not the brightest
bulb in the pack so he realizes as he
launches into this invective against the
people
who don't wear the masks and don't
listen to the experts even when the
experts change their mind all the time
in the 316th day of slow the spread as
he realizes
he's as he's going through this this
motion
he realizes he's not wearing the mask
through slices and people they're not
listening to the mask mandates in their
whoopsy daisy and they're not no no no
no we're going to be not known forever
i'm michael knowles it's the michael
knowles show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday from wesley beyer
who says chuck schumer's freudian slip
wasn't
wrong at all i mean there was an
uprising
that's you can't joke about that you're
not that's this is too serious you're
not allowed to make that kind of joke
but it's pretty
pretty funny you know
we all need a little bit more energy i
think these days
watching what dur that very sleepy press
conference i think we all could use a
little more energy that's why we need
liquid iv you all probably know liquid
iv for their very popular hydration
drink mix well i certainly like that
especially maybe if i'm exercise
more likely if i'm out having a couple
coca-colas with the boys the next day it
makes you feel more hydrated and better
however you've got to check out their
energy multiplier it is an absolute game
changer
gives you that little extra boost that
we all need we can all
probably agree that 2020 was rough uh
2021 not not looking that much better
one way to start it out on a better foot
though is to get a little more energy
one stick
of liquid ivs energy multiplier is like
drinking two cups of coffee
it's an all-natural alternative to
processed energy drinks
for a sustained energy boost throughout
the day half of americans report that
they struggle with daily fatigue
especially if you have a newborn baby
you probably look a little fatigued
uh don't do it don't don't suffer
through it when
you have a solution grab your energy
liquid iv in bulk nationwide at costco
or you can get 25 off when you go to
liquidity.com and use code michael at
checkout that is 25
off anything you order when you use
promo code michael at liquid iv.com
start fueling your adventures today
liquid iv.com promo code
michael i love liquid iv great way to
stay hydrated great way to get energy
go check out liquid iv today
president biden finally gets the message
because
and i said this in the months before the
presidential election i said you know
we've all been joking about how the
virus is going to be cured the day after
the election
but i'm not so sure because this is a
tremendous amount of power
that liberal elites have grabbed power
in the administrative state power in
elective office
power in corporate america especially
big big business like amazon for
instance
uh power in all of these various sectors
i don't think they're going to give it
up so quickly
and that seems to have been proven
correct now they're going to say no it's
going to go on and on and on
we're going to have to keep watching
ourselves why is this dragging on
because people aren't wearing masks now
of course that doesn't
make any sense at all the places with
the most draconian mask policies
the places with some of the highest mass
compliance in the world
are also some of the cities where the
virus has been surging
not not uh uniformly and there are
plenty of places where people aren't
wearing masks and the virus is surging
too
just to say that perhaps fauci's
original guidance
that the masks are not quite as
effective as people think
maybe that was correct but fauces
changed his mind yesterday we reported
on this new idea from the new york times
that people should wear multiple masks
and i i began to say
that this was fauci's new bright idea
but i said no fauci himself
hasn't said it yet i knew he was going
to
because fauci just goes along with
whatever political current is
convenient for him but at that time he
hadn't said it
it took him about 12 hours to say now
he's going along to
dr fausch he says come on guys it's
common sense just wear two masks
a lot of folks are hearing now about
double masking
wearing two masks or trying to get one
of those n95 medical grade masks
do you believe that that's advisable and
makes a difference
you know it it likely does because i
mean this is a
physical covering to prevent
droplets and virus to get in so if you
have a physical covering with one layer
you put another layer on it just makes
common sense
that it likely would be more effective
and that's the reason why you see people
either double masking or doing a version
of an n95
dr fauci if it's just common sense
that we should all be wearing two masks
all of a sudden
that's just common sense and it's
obviously going to provide more
protection against the virus
why wouldn't you have told us that 10
months ago we this has been going
on for 10 months we are
closing in on a year of this epidemic if
this is
common sense that we should just wear
two masks i guess pretty soon it's gonna
be three masks pretty soon you're gonna
put a doughnut on your head
and hop up and down on a pogo stick it's
common sense if that's common sense
what took so long because fauci says it
and he seems totally reasonable he goes
look
hey thanks so much for having me on look
guys it's common sense all right just
just do it i'm a follow the science kind
of guy i'm a science guy
forget about i have no political views
just do exactly what i say because it's
science
but he sounded just as reasonable he
sounded just as
scientific when 10 months ago
he said it was common sense that the
masks don't do
nothing right now people should not be
walked there's no reason to be walking
around with a mask
when you're in the middle of an outbreak
wearing a mask might make people
feel a little bit better and it might
even block
a droplet but it's not providing the
perfect protection that people
think that it is and often there are
unintended consequences people keep
fiddling with the mask and they keep
touching their face
there is no reason to wear a mask
says dr fauci in a perfectly common
sensical way
in fact maybe it stops a droplet okay
but there could be unintended
consequences that actually make all this
worse no reason to it makes people feel
better but come on
guys come use your head common sense
until faculty says use your head it's
common sense
to wear two masks or three masks or four
masks
it's common sense this is really
pathetic that anybody is listening to
this guy anymore
it's sad i'm not saying this in a
condemnatory way i'm not
i'm not even making fun of people i i
pity the people who still
think that this guy has any credibility
or that any of these
technocrats have any credibility
these doctor dictators it's a sad thing
you've got to think for yourself use
your common sense listen to dr fauci
only in this regard use your common
sense
and they're all now they're all
condemning the former president the
former administration they're
all running as quickly as they can oh
it's so good to be
in an administration now that believes
in science and lets these
these technocrats do whatever they want
fatchi is not the only one jerome adams
who is the former surgeon general under
president trump
he is coming out now and
begging the liberal elite and the
establishment and the media
for forgiveness for committing the
heinous crime of
working as the surgeon general in the
trump administration and that is
really pitiful i feel he seems like a
nice enough guy and he's an impressive
guy in his own right isn't he an admiral
his
surgeon general but it's pathetic what
he's reduced himself to
and and the way in which he's begging
forgiveness is even more pathetic
jerome adams writes quote people so
freely suggest they would have left
the trump administration but hold the
one woman in the room to a different
standard
if dr burks or i weren't there many
medical
public health conversations would have
had no input whatsoever
from a woman or a person of color that's
a heavy cross to bear are you kidding me
let me ask you i i'm going to try to
make this point in a
the least provocative way i can because
i know we're living in a very
politically correct culture
what is the benefit to the study of a
virus
in the implementation of policies that
will
slow the spread of the virus what is the
benefit in and of itself
of having a woman or a person of color
give that opinion
what is what what medical and scientific
benefit
is derived from dr burke's genitals
or jerome adams's skin color that
uniquely qualified him
to give advice on the virus first of all
as far as i can tell
that entire team of genius technocrat
virus experts of all colors and all
sexes
completely botched the public health
messaging the one thing they got right
was how quickly they got the vaccine out
everything else they completely screwed
up so not a big recommendation but how
pathetic this guy jerome adams is a real
guy
admiral career of military service
rose to the highest level of his
profession in the government
surgeon general of the united states and
the the
best thing he can say to recommend
himself is the color of his skin
what a bizarre world we're living in
that that's the case
why on earth does this have to be a race
thing
because race in particular but sex also
and all of these various identity groups
has become a national
obsession it's and it's used by the left
in a very destructive way and it
was developed over the course of at
least 100 years and this is actually
part of my new book that's coming out
pretty soon speechless controlling words
controlling minds just a little plug in
there
you can pre-order it but it's not going
to be out for a few months
this was developed intentionally by the
left as a means of
subverting the traditional standards and
getting all americans to hate one
another and
implementing their their agenda but it's
not just the left
conservatives buy into this identity
politics stuff too
they are they are so afraid of being
called a sexist or a racist or this
phobe
or that phobe that they play into this
sort of thing and i don't think it's
respectful
i think what jerome adams is saying here
is is so debasing he's so degrading
himself
by stooping to this level by first of
all by apologizing for serving a surgeon
general
and then under the mean orange man and
then
defending it on the race card
or defending berks on the sex card
that's pathetic unfortunately though
conservatives play into this sometimes
too and it gets to one of the great
national debates of the last six hours
that seems trivial but actually i think
is important which we'll get to in a
second first though i got to thank our
friends over at ring
ring makes me feel safe makes sweet
little lisa feel safe
makes sweet little baby boy noles feel
safe too there's a lot going on at our
front doors these days
especially for me because i got not only
do i have my house when i moved to
tennessee not only do i have all the
moving and all that kind of stuff going
on
i got this new kid at home so i want to
make sure that i can see who is outside
the door before we open the door that is
one reason i love rings video doorbell
you can see
here and speak to whoever is at the door
from anywhere the doorbell rings
you don't need to guess maybe it's the
pizza delivery guy you want to open it
up maybe it's
you know the guy bringing your packages
you open it up maybe it's
maybe it's your mother-in-law and you
stay very very quiet with
ring you can just check it out right
away right now you can get a special
offer on the ring
welcome kit at ring.com knowles
k-w-l-e-s
this comes with rings video doorbell 3
and chime pro
which is the perfect way to upgrade your
front door
and start your ring experience it also
makes a great housewarming gift
which i have given out to my friends
because you know it's safe it's cool
it's futuristic
and it isn't that expensive so you get
credit for a great gift
you don't shell out a lot of money go to
ring.com knowles ring.com
knowles we are having the latest stage
of a debate that has raged for years and
years at this point
over whether or not we should replace
andrew jackson on the 20
bill i know this debate seems
trivial most people say who cares
the left cares because they've been
pushing this for a long time
the left cares a lot and maybe there's a
reason for that
you know the left cares a lot about
these things that seem kind of small
like
for instance gendered bathrooms right
the idea that
men have to use the men's room and women
have to use the women's room they say i
want someone
men to be able to use the women's room
and what a lot of conservatives say oh
who cares
well the left cares and
their care about it is not frivolous
they realize that in this
symbol this sort of in itself a
relatively minor act
they can get a whole lot more of their
political premises across
that's what we're seeing here the the
proposal is to replace andrew jackson on
the 20
bill with harriet tubman harriet tubman
the slave who
escaped and got lots of other slaves to
to be freed as well developed the
underground railroad
supported john brown who was the great
abolitionist
and so therefore we should put her on
the 20 bill
i'm against this idea i'm not against
this idea because i don't like harriet
tubman harriet tubman is a very
admirable american
i'm against this idea because
of the political message that
the left is trying to push with it and
that conservatives are acquiescing to i
would say most conservatives i know
are for replacing andrew jackson on the
20 bill with harriet tubman specifically
and the argument usually goes something
like this they say
well andrew jackson's the founder of the
democratic party
and harriet tubman's a gun-toting
republican so yeah fine by me folks
that's okay that's kind of what you hear
in the general
kind of conservative blue check mark uh
sphere
however you'll notice that the people
who are actually
pushing this not the people who are
acquiescing to it but the people who are
pushing this
are democrats and the people who have
resisted it
are republicans president trump slowed
this process down for four years
it was supposed to happen four years ago
he put the kibosh on it now it seems to
be speeding up again
so why is that why is it that the
democrats are pushing the gun-toting
republican
and the republican is defending the
founder of the democratic party
well what people will tell you
usually leftists but i suppose some
conservatives do will tell you is the
reason
that p anyone would oppose this idea is
because you're a racist
because you don't want black people on
money that's why
right and there it is there there it is
and i think a lot of the reason that
republicans
are so quick to jump out and say no i'm
for it i think it's great it's because
they
they're doing the thing that republicans
always do which is trying to prove to
the left that we're not racists
uh which is a fool's errand because the
left
first of all the left harbors much more
racial bigotry than the right
does i think that's without question at
this point they're instituting
legal racial discrimination on the left
uh but also the left doesn't care they
don't care that we're not racist or
bigots or whatever it's just
they're just using it as a cudgel we're
we're not uh you know bigoted
but that's sort of beside the point
we're talking about this issue here
i think what the move to to put tubman
on the bill is for
is largely to get rid of andrew jackson
andrew jackson has been much maligned in
this country
over the past couple of decades and
republicans have gone along with it you
know sort of cynically they want to
prove they're not racists i think but
also because
he's the founder of the democratic party
andrew jackson is a great american he
was a hero of new orleans
he was an important president he was a
good american leader
he had many flaws as do we all
and and great men have great flaws but
the the attack on andrew jackson is a
way to attack
our traditions and our founding fathers
and all the great men that we've revered
they always go for the easy ones first
they all they always ban alex jones from
the internet
before they ban donald trump right they
they want to ban the guys that nobody's
going to defend
and then they ramp it up and then they
ramp it up and then they ramp it up and
then they go for the sitting president
of the united states and whole
scores of mainstream conservatives it's
the same thing with historical figures
first they go for robert e lee what are
you some kind of confederate what are
you some kind of racist
and conservatives who who understand
what this game is about say
wait a second it's not about robert lee
they're going to go after
washington they're going to go after
jefferson remember trump said that in a
speech
and the left says no that's not true and
then the squishy republicans say no
that's not true lee's terrible he's all
we got to get rid of lee
and then two seconds later they're
toppling statues of washington
they're erasing his name from buildings
they're getting rid of jefferson they're
getting rid of because there's no end to
it
so sure we get this little victory yeah
we topple the leader of the founder of
the democratic party okay
they're coming for all of them too and
it's based on this idea by the way
that is identity politics
i think harriet tubman could deserve i
mean she's been honored in many ways in
this country but sure put her on some
denomination or something put her on
some money
make up a coin like they did for
sacagawea give harriet tubman some money
that's fine
it wouldn't be enough because it's about
replacing andrew jackson and i think
harriet tubman is being used here
because of her sex and
even more so because of her race if this
is really just about putting an
abolitionist on money
why wouldn't we put john brown on the
money why not replace andrew jackson
with john brown
harriet tubman herself greatly admired
john brown said that john brown
in his death did more than a hundred men
could
living harriet tubman aided
john brown not in the actual raid on
harper's ferry
for which he was most famous because she
was either recovering from a sickness or
whatever
she was she couldn't be found at that
point but she did aid him quite a lot so
why not john brent well john brown's a
white guy
i mean the people who are pushing this
are they don't care about harriet tubman
they just care about identity politics
and and we give in on this because we
all like harriet tubman
but we're giving them this premise
when we replace a great american andrew
jackson
when we fail to defend more broadly our
american tradition
don't do it don't fall for it it's a
trick i mean i i get why
political correctness has succeeded i
get why the left has been so successful
on the cultural front for the last 50
years certainly and really for the last
hundred years
because it's so subtle it's so hard to
defend but i think
i think we should speaking of these
sorts of putting people
of various backgrounds on money sh i
should remind you by the way it's not as
though we don't have
women of color on money we sacagawea i
just mentioned we had pocahontas on
money as early as 1865.
we had her on banknotes uh israelis 1865
not
uh not elizabeth warren who would not be
a woman of color but
but the actual pocahontas well speaking
of pocahontas and these tedious racial
politics
disney plus is banning classic movies
from young audiences audiences under
seven
namely the people who watch disney
movies
which movies dumbo peter pan swiss
family robinson and the aristocats
no longer available for young users
on the disney plus streaming service
why you ask well because of political
incorrectness
because of racism here's why your kid
can't watch peter pan right now in
disney plus
quote the film portrays native people in
a stereotypical
manner that reflects neither the
diversity of native peoples
nor their authentic cultural traditions
it shows them speaking in an
unintelligible language
and repeatedly refers to them as
redskins an offensive term
according to white liberals but not not
really deemed defensive by
indians themselves peter and the lost
boys engage in dancing wearing
headdresses and other exaggerated tropes
a form of mockery and appropriation of
native people's culture
and imagery all of that's gobbledygook
and it's completely meaningless
culture requires appropriation
if you want to become cultured you need
to appropriate different aspects
of culture you need to
behave in certain ways you need to speak
in certain ways you need to
develop and cultivate cultivate from the
same word as culture
certain tastes
i'll i'll try to be as i always tell you
i try to be
as unprovocative as i possibly can i'm
italian
i am well aware of italian stereotypes
we like eating lasagna we talk with our
hands as you can see i'm doing right now
we have certain uh
stereotypes that go along with that
culture right
if i strip away all of those stereotypes
i take away all the lasagna all the
pizza all the bippity boppity boo all
the speaking with your hands all that
kind of stuff
all of the physical characteristics
because i don't want to be racist or
culturally appropriative
i have just erased the culture
i have ironically done the thing that
the
left pretends they don't want to do
right because the left castigates
conservatives when we appropriate
culture
but they also castigate conservatives
when we don't appropriate culture when
we erase culture
it's a it's a damned if you do damned if
you do scenario
but we give into this because we're so
afraid of being called racist or
whatever
don't do it racism isn't bad because
it's an offense to human dignity that's
why we shouldn't do it
good done put that in a box tuck it away
you're good don't worry about it anymore
don't worry what these
cynics and idiots and nefarious
political actors
think about you got to get got to get
rid of political correctness folks
that's what we're trying to do here at
the daily wire earlier this month we
released our first film
run high to fight exclusively for daily
wire members
we picked up run hide fight after
hollywood studios turned down the quote
distasteful subject matter because it
didn't include leftist talking points
wasn't pro-gun control
celebrated heroic bravery instead of
glorifying mass shooters
early critic reviews for the movie were
uh negative
they didn't like it at all so then we
released it for you guys and then the
audience score jumped up to like 93
or something with over 2 000 reviews so
the critic score is like negative 93
the audience review is positive 93 and
uh
that's usually the movie i want to see
you can watch it over at dailywire.com
you can watch it on our mobile app you
can watch it on
our streaming apps at apple tv and roku
if you're not a daily wire member
what are you doing use promo code rhf
to get 25 off that is rhf for 25 off
we'll be right back with a lot more
these racial identity politics are
they they've been farcical for a long
time but they're they're becoming
even more so and it would seem that
there's no limit for it
what has happened right now in
politically correct culture either locus
and whatever you want to call it
intersectionality
is that white has just become a
synonym for bad right whiteness
is an actual term that people use is
simply a synonym for
a bat for bad thing badness evil
that's why we have to eradicate
whiteness we need to root out our own
whiteness i mean it's it's being used
really
if you want to be very specific about it
to refer to original sin
the fallen nature of man which is now
formerly we understood that this was a
universal
aspect of our human nature now it's
being wielded by
political leftists to suggest that only
some people are guilty of this and
they've caused all the problems in the
world part of this also is because of
the
we could go on for hours and hours about
this but because of the left's
anthropology because over the past
certainly 150 or so years
the the left has indulged these theories
that man is essentially good
but that society is what corrupts him
and so
you know you just need to perfect
politics you need to perfect especially
education
and then once you do that crime and
disease and everything is going to go
away
that raises the question of course if if
individual men
are good how come society got bad
but one way that the the present day
left is answering that
is they're saying well people are good
generally but there's this one group of
people that's bad
and they have this thing which is evil
and it's called whiteness and so we've
got to root that out
and that lies at the heart of a lot of
this intersectional kind of racial
id politics this is now being wielded
by lazy teachers in washington state as
an excuse
not to go back to work so it's being
used for
and like hey johnny why didn't you
finish your homework oh you know man
white supremacy and stuff i can't i
didn't do it hey
how come you didn't wash the dishes ah
man you know white supremacy that's why
why else so the head of the washington
state teachers union claimed last week
that reopening schools for in-person
learning
uh ten months after two weeks to slow
the spread
is not only an example of white
supremacy
but furthermore when when objections
were brought up pointing out that
students are really suffering from this
las vegas just had to reopen their
schools because students are committing
suicide at much higher rates
students mental health is deteriorating
well the head of the teachers union said
that concerns over students mental
health are a form of quote
white privilege white privilege
this this comes after the chicago
teachers union
also refused to go back to work also for
the same reason they said that reopening
schools for in-person instruction is
racist and sexist and
the president of the pasco association
of educators in
washington state went on what our friend
jason rants up there referred to as a
series of
unhinged remarks at this school board
meeting
the city of chicago moving then down to
illinois city of chicago wants the
teachers to go back to work
teachers union doesn't want to do it the
chicago public schools now are issuing a
warning they're saying
if you don't show up for work on monday
you will be deemed absent without leave
and will not be eligible for
pay this is good they should
do that this is actually what ronald
reagan did
in the 1980s when the air traffic
controllers went on strike public unions
are not supposed to be able to strike
because while a company might be able to
shut down for a little bit the
government is not permitted to shut down
so you know for years and years liberal
politicians had indulged this sort of
thing the government worker unions
striking in violation of the law reagan
didn't do it he came out
and said if you don't show up to work
you violated your your
terms of contract and you'll be
terminated it is for this reason
that i must tell those who fail to
report for duty this morning
they are in violation of the law and if
they do not report for work within 48
hours
they have forfeited their jobs and will
be terminated
a classic reagan i mean this is one of
his stellar moments
and the union didn't really believe him
because the entire liberal establishment
was was egging the the air traffic
controllers on
so one of the reporters in that press
conference after reagan finished
speaking he says wait a second wait a
second what you're going to fire them
can't there be some kind of lesser
action and then reagan
the actor comes out and musters all of
his hollywood chops and
just sort of feigns indignation or maybe
it was sincere indignation he says
what a lesser action what are you
talking about
such strong action as your first action
why not
a lesser action at this point
what lesser action can there be the law
is very explicit
they are violating the law and as i say
we call this to the attention of their
leadership whether this was conveyed to
the membership before they voted to
strike i don't know
but this is one of the reasons why there
could be no further negotiation
while this situation continues
you can't sit and negotiate with a union
that's in violation of the law
and their oath and their oath what
what lesser action can there be there is
just a great
it's a great moment and and uh
incredibly now
you have the democratic mayor of chicago
lori lightfoot
basically saying the same thing a little
softer than ronald reagan
but still coming out and saying look
guys you have to you have to go back to
work
even i liberal left-wing lori life what
i'm saying
it's been 10 months you know go back to
work but no
because the the left has given
ideologues
across the sexual and racial spectrum
and
excuse this blank check you can blame
all of your problems on
white supremacy or whatever you know
they come up with new terms all the time
but
today that would appear to be the term
and it's
very harmful to believe that sort of
thing just for your own personal growth
and it's it's
absolute poison to society and our
current president
joe biden is letting letting these guys
get away with it he was asked a question
directly during a press conference about
the teachers unions
refusing to go back to school and
classic slippery joe he just completely
dances around it
do you believe sir the teachers should
return to schools
now i believe we should make
school classrooms safe and secure
for the students for the teachers
and for the the help that's in those
schools
maintaining the facilities we need new
ventilation systems in those schools
we need testing for people coming in and
out of the classes we need testing for
teachers as well as students and we need
the capacity
the capacity to know that in fact the
the sake of the circumstance in the
school is safe and secure for everyone
joe can you answer the question though
because that had absolutely nothing to
do with the question that was asked
joe biden was asked should teachers go
back to school now
it says i think teachers should be safe
and
schools should be clean
uh-huh hey quick poll here's a quick
audience poll
do you think schools should be filthy
and dangerous
how many people raise your hand if you
think oh nobody okay
okay right we all agree with that joe
but
you have to lead you need you need to
give an answer here
should teachers go back to work 10
months after their two-week vacation
duh of course they should he can't say
that because he's beholden to the
teacher unions
this this reminds me this tactic mike
bloomberg used this to
when bloomberg wants to basically
overturn the second amendment and it's
been his
crusade for decades now but he knows
that if you come out and say
billionaires against the second
amendment that that doesn't look very
good
so bloomberg started this campaign he
called it mayors again not billionaires
against he said mayors against
illegal guns mayors against illegal guns
how many people do you know who are for
illegal guns i guess some
probably some people are for them but
generally speaking people are for legal
guns
we want to make more guns legal right i
think certain guns that are currently
illegal should be made legal
but nobody's for illegal guns really but
he has to say that because it sounds
it sounds more palatable that's joe
biden
presidents for safe clean classrooms
okay sure but you want you won't give
the answer by the way there's a study
out now
you know i know the left love studies i
take them with a grain of salt but i'll
use them when they suit my purposes
new study produced in the united kingdom
by the office for national statistics
examined rates of death from kovid
among teachers shows that death rates
among teachers
are not higher than among the general
population there is no specific
threat to teachers lives if they go back
and go to work like the rest of us
remember i thought i thought teachers
were supposed to do this very
sacred important duty of raising up the
next generation and they're some of the
greatest heroes in the country and i'm
not even really being
facetious here i i have a great respect
for education
i have a great respect for my teachers
specifically they've had some of the
greatest
greatest impact of my life on my life of
anybody so i'm actually
buying into that that argument to a
large degree they sure ain't acting like
it though are they
no they're they're trying to
get now what a year off of work
with full pay and in some of these
places their pay is pretty good
because of the negotiations of the
unions buying off politicians like joe
biden
how corrupt but this is the kind of
corruption we're we're just gonna see
for however long this charade lasts cnn
ran a chiron yesterday that sums it all
up
they were playing clips of jen saki
she's the new press secretary
and the chiron read saki
promises to share accurate info
and then in parentheses how refreshing
that kind of fawning coverage for the
state and for the regime
would make kim jong-un blush i
never want to hear again about the
the tyrannical rule of i don't know
vladimir putin
vladimir putin does not have as cozy a
relationship to his state media
as the american regime the liberal
regime has
to cnn and the washington post and the
new york times
and nbc and abc and cbs and all the rest
of them
with i guess sort of the exception of
fox news
and the smaller networks and newsmax and
oan
oh newsmax and noaa are quite
conservative but they're smaller they
have a smaller reach
and fox news is somewhat conservative i
don't know
sort of like not always very liberal
i mean in 2020 i don't know obviously
the network repositioned itself a little
bit but
that is not the recipe for
a serious self-governing republic
it's a it's a grift it's a grift all the
way down
you you've you see this you've got the
media obviously you've got
big technology backing up the regime
you've got education backing up the
regime
you've got all of these groups it's a
grift i don't
use that word grift too often because i
think it's an overused word and it's
used imprecisely right now you know
a con or something like that but with
biden it really is a grift i mean biden
has sold his influence
just like the clintons uh you you saw
this in all of hunter biden scandals but
even even the other day there was a big
headline
they said the presidential motorcade
stopped in washington dc
so that hunter biden could run out and
pick up bagels for him and his dad
and i saw this story and it was some
kind of kooky story oh wow how funny
they stopped the motorcades
every day joe is going out and getting
bagels right and the second i saw that
headline i said
this is a grift this is a grift there is
obviously
something shady about this i google for
two seconds and i find out what it is
joe biden coming back from mass
from which he should be excommunicated
but whatever
guess he's not it's above my pay grade
to make that determination so the
motorcade stops for nine minutes
so hunter can go get bagels at a shop
called call your mother
to pick up the takeout order okay go
call your mother or what's up with this
bagel shop
oh joe biden's coronavirus response
director jeff zines is a major
investor in that delhi according to the
atlantic
which first discovered this so joe biden
i assume he can get a bagel at the white
house right i don't think the president
of the united states like
you and i if we go to church we drive
home
maybe we're going to pick up breakfast
along the way bring it home eat it on
the couch if you're the president of the
united states someone will bring you
bagels you probably have many bagels in
the white house
but he stops there he stops the
motorcade for nine minutes to get a lot
of publicity
to his friend's bagel shop so that it
can become very popular and his friend
can make more money this is
the way politicians generally work and
it's the way that joe biden
has worked especially that is joe
biden's career is
backslapping you do me a favor i'll do
you a favor
hey you better fire that prosecutor
looking into my son otherwise you're not
getting a billion dollars son of a [ __ ]
he fired him ha ha
backslapping joe that is what we are
getting a whole
lot more of
this is a scary growth of state power
because it's not just the state in the
kind of narrow sense of the government
it's all these affiliated groups the
public-private partnerships nothing like
the president of the united states to
plug your your bagel shop to really get
to really show that coziness between the
public and private sector
but it's as we've said it's education
it's technology it's the media it's all
these things
they all form the blob they all form the
liberal establishment
and they are all seriously threatening
our
liberties most notably because they're
going to keep us locked down
for months and months and months and
months according to the president
but it's scarier than that
there's a purpose to the growth of all
this kind of
state power and i use that term state
broadly to include
tech and education and all those sorts
of things
and the media notably
the most disturbing story i've seen on
cnn in quite some time
occurred over just the past few days an
18 year old
guy jackson refered turned his dad
in to the fbi because his dad
went to the stop the steel rally
at at capitol hill i maybe he was part
of the riot i'm not sure
he was certainly around the area and so
this
this kid calls the fbi to turn his dad
in because his dad said hey
if you turn me in you're a traitor i
guess the kid had been threatening to
turn him in or suggested he might turn
him in he says if you turn me in you're
a traitor and you know what happens to
traitors
what happens to they get capital
punishment so this kid
calls the fbi gets his father arrested
and then cnn has him on to talk about
the wonderful story now
maybe you're of a of two minds on this
man maybe the kid maybe it was a serious
threat maybe he had to turn his dad in
well i don't know it doesn't sound like
a serious threat listen to
reffitt tell the story to cuomo who's
lapping it up
i know you love your family and i know
this is hard
so help people understand why did you
feel you had to let authorities know
about what was being done to your father
and what was happening in his own head
um i don't really know how to explain it
it was uh it was just
it just felt like the right thing
regardless of my emotions
and how i felt and how much i loved my
family and my dad
i was worried i didn't think he would
actually do anything bad
but him saying anything even remotely
threatening to me and my sister and
my family and government officials it
was just too much
now listen here this is an important
point that he's making
he's because presumably the reason he
called the
fbi and his dad is because his dad
threatened to kill him right he says
you're you'd be a traitor you know what
happens to traitors
but the kid says right here he doesn't
think his dad would have done anything
bad he doesn't actually think it was a
threat
but he turned his dad into the fbi
anyway his dad since been arrested
why did he do it well he makes clear
it's because they have different
political views
it's been definitely over the past four
years that it's grown
and just snowballed into what my dad's
become now and he's still my father but
he's
he's changed a lot household
he's been more active on his
on the internet and
obviously the militia and the far-right
extremists he's been involved with
recently
he's been a lot more i don't want to say
aggressive
but more uh
more uh scared
would he talk to you about it no
uh i actually never even knew he was
going to dc
until the day he left i'm
sure it was because of my political
views but i'm not sure
and there there you have it i'm sure
it's because of my political views
presumably this kid is quite left-wing
and then he posted a fundraiser because
his
mother kicked him out of the house for
getting his father arrested and
uh from the picture you know he's
wearing like he's got very long hair
he's wearing a pink hat he's where he he
doesn't look like a right right-wing
conservative
i'm i'm not even really attacking this
kid i mean
he's 18 years old i guess he's an adult
and it's wrong to
get your father arrested generally
speaking especially for just being a
republican but uh i'm not attacking this
game my heart kind of breaks for this
kid
and certainly it breaks for the family
the
the sisters and the mother who who the
kid acknowledges he says oh yeah i've
broken their hearts i've totally
destroyed their lives yeah because i got
my dad arrested but i felt like i had to
do it i'd do it again
and chris cuomo that disgusting man
lapping it up so happy oh yeah tell me
more about how you got your dad arrested
because he's so right-wing
yeah tell me oh you had to do it you had
to do it
i i mentioned this whole story not even
to comment on the kid or the dad or or
even chris cuomo
i bring up the story because it
has a lot to do with how the left
operates it actually tells you a lot
about the difference between
the right and the left they begin with
different
fundamentally different views of society
and their political agendas are oriented
according to those premises so for
conservatives the fundamental building
block of society is the family
it's not the individual it's the family
that is the fundamental building block
we are not born as free-floating atoms
flying around in outer space and then we
land and through our
consent we choose to join a family it's
not how it works
we are born out of an act of love
between our parents
and at a higher level out of the act of
love of god our creator
who creates the world through an act of
speech let there be light
and so on and we are born with duties
with obligations with loyalties
we are stewards of ourselves our life
which is a gift from
from our parents as approximate cause
and from god ultimately
and we are stewards of this creation
that's where conservatives begin
the left and i include liberals in this
i include libertarians in this
the left libertarian certainly begin
with this idea that the individual is
the building block of society and we
have
we are born primarily to rights and
entitlement and not loyalty and not duty
and not obligation
but i darn it i better get mine all
oriented toward the ultimate liberation
and that liberation
must occur by overcoming the
institutions of society
which now we use the term white
supremacy i guess is the kind it's the
term
du jour it's a fetish idea but you you
hear all the patriarchy is another one
of these
and ultimately the family which is that
bedrock institution it's
the smallest political institution you
can have of multiple people in society
organically
that is why the left is always
attempting to destroy the family
to destroy the family by any means
necessary by redefining the family
by taking power away from the family by
increasing the role of the state this is
why even radical individualists
sometimes become defenders of state
power because if the fundamental unit of
society is the individual
then the only way to do anything
together is by amassing all those
individuals together
which is that that is truly the theory
of fascism and it's in the
true meaning of that word where you
bundle all the sticks together and
in the state and the state is the
highest good and of course
the progressive left has this exalted
view of the state
and maybe even mainstream liberals
haven't exalted you those are different
scenarios and you're going to see a
whole lot more of this it's deeply
disturbing but this is what it looks
like
we talk about it in the abstract a lot
this is what it looks like on the
granular level
and this is going to be a process that
goes on like the lockdowns according to
biden for months and months and months
and months and even longer i'm michael
knowles this is the michael knowles show
see you tomorrow
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boary
our technical director is austin stevens
supervising producers
mathis glover and robert sterling
production manager
pavel vadofsky editor and associate
producer
danny d'amico audio mixer mike coromina
hair and makeup by nikka geneva and
production coordinator
mckenna waters the michael knowles show
is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021 if you prefer
facts over feelings aren't
offended by the brutal truth and you can
still laugh at the insanity filling our
national news cycle well tune in to the
ben shapiro show we'll get a whole lot
of that and much more
see you there